se termine aujourd'hui avec vous Madame
la Ministre
un cycle d'audition et de déplacement
qui a commencé le 8 février
2023 pendant ces quatre mois nous avons
eu pour objectif d'évaluer les besoins
de rénovation des écoles collèges et
lycées liés à la transition écologique
d'identifier les défis notamment
juridiques et financier de cette
rénovation pour les collectivités
territoriales et de mesurer l'efficacité
de l'accompagnement des décideurs locaux
sur le terrain le 28 juin notre
rapporteur nous présentera son rapport
et ses recommandations comme je disais
que c'était terminé ce n'est pas pour
tout le monde
ce qui reste quelques semaines d'efforts
encore il était donc important que nous
puissions évoquer avec vous les constats
qui ont émergé de nos travaux et de la
consultation des élus locaux à laquelle
nous avons procédé sur le site du Sénat
nous avons ainsi réuni plus de 1300
témoignages d'élus qui confirment la
difficulté plus particulièrement pour
les communes de conduire les projets de
rénovation des bâtiments scolaires dont
la crise de l'énergie renforce l'intérêt
et que le droit européen et la loi
française rendent oblique rend
obligatoire pour la plupart des
établissements scolaires
cette audition vient à poignée quelques
jours après l'annonce par le
gouvernement d'un plan de rénovation des
écoles que vous allez nous présenter
après l'intervention de notre rapporteur
Nadège avait
à qui je donnerai la parole madame la
ministre nous aurons ensemble à temps
d'échange je rappelle je rappelle avant
de donner la parole à la rapporteur que
cette audition donnera lieu à un compte
rendu écrit qui sera annexé à notre
rapport et que son enregistrement vidéo
sera accessible sur le site du Sénat
la rapporteur merci monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre merci du
temps que vous nous accordez sur cette
mission
monsieur le Président de l'a dit le 9
mai le plan de rénovation énergétique
des écoles a été annoncée il s'appuie
sur la mobilisation divers leviers
financiers subventions prêts des crédits
sont ainsi fléchés au sein du fond
chaleur et du fond vert s'agit-il de
crédit nouveau ou d'enveloppe dédiée à
la rénovation des écoles imputées sur
des crédits existants en d'autres termes
ce plan fait-il l'objet d'un effort
spécifique la communication du ministère
de la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires évoqués à ce
propos de ce plan le défi du siècle
compte tenu du coup de ces rénovations
comment l'ampleur des moyens sera-t-elle
dimensionné
le plomb annonce la rénovation de 10 000
écoles or sur les quelques 51
000 écoles collèges et lycées recensés
sur l'ensemble du territoire seulement
14% répondent aux normes à basse
consommation visé par le décret
comment vont être choisis les dix mille
écoles qui se
quels seront les bâtiments pardon qui
seront aidés par ce nouveau plan alors
même qu'il n'existe pas d'état des lieux
actuellement à l'échelle du territoire
qui permettrait de connaître précisément
l'état actuel de ces bâtiments au regard
des normes environnementales de savoir
ce qui a déjà été fait pour améliorer
cet état et d'identifier ce qui reste à
entreprendre pour atteindre les
objectifs du décret tertiaire et des
textes européens de préparation je vous
remercie de vous répondre
j'ai une troisième question mais on va
d'abord répondre à celle-ci
le président madame la rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs tout
d'abord sur la méthode j'avais un petit
texte où je pensais à répondre à votre
sorte de résumé de votre rapport est-ce
que je passe directement à la réponse à
votre question comment voulez-vous
procéder qu'est-ce qui vous
convient de faire je vous propose de
présenter les choses telles que vous ne
l'aviez prévu comme ça c'est aussi
simple il y aura un échange ensuite
parfait donc quelques éléments sur un
sujet comme vous l'avez dit qui est
crucial
fondamentale et vous modifiez
aujourd'hui sur la question du bâtis
scolaire une question
cruciale pour assurer l'éducation de nos
enfants et nos petits-enfants la
rénovation énergétique des écoles est en
effet une initiative essentielle pour
réduire notre consommation énergétique
améliorer la qualité de vie des élèves
réduire notre empreinte carbone et
lutter efficacement contre le changement
climatique
tout cela justifie l'utilisation
d'outils de financement innovant tels
que le tiers financement ou les
certificats d'économie d'énergie comme
ma collègue Agnès renacher ministre la
transition énergétique a dû vous les
présenter pour en parler si vous le
souhaitez un petit peu après mais
surtout cette initiative implique que
soit portée une attention toute
particulière aux élus locaux afin que
l'État soit en mesure de vous
accompagner dans la territorialisation
de la transition écologique pilotée par
mon ministre de tutelle Christophe bichu
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires le besoin
d'investissement en faveur de la
rénovation énergétique des écoles est
aujourd'hui évaluée à 5,2 milliards
d'euros par an
soit plus du double du niveau actuel de
financement l'enjeu est donc de taille
car il s'agit de s'attaquer à la
rénovation de 44
000 écoles publiques du premier degré
représentant 50 millions de mètres
carrés soit un sixième des bâtiments des
collectivités territoriales si la
compétence construction est entretient
et de la responsabilité des communes et
parfois des intercommunalités lorsque la
compétence a été transférée un tel défi
ne peut pas être réalisé collectivement
sans le soutien de l'État et de ses
partenaires notamment région et
départements c'est ce qui nous a conduit
à élaborer un plan spécifique pour les
écoles qu'elle soit dans nos villes ou
dans nos villages aujourd'hui le plan
porté par le gouvernement nous permet de
bâtir avec nos partenaires publics et
privés au premier handical la banque des
territoires une feuille de route
crédible entre l'État et les corrects et
les collectivités territoriales avant de
répondre à vos questions je souhaite
rappeler qu'avec les dotations
d'investissement classique en premier
lieu la décile et la DETR c'est près de
6500 projets sur les bâtiments scolaires
qui ont été soutenus en 2021 pour un
soutien de près de 200 millions d'euros
les dotations de droit commun sont ainsi
largement mobilisés sur ce sujet en 2023
et elle continueront de l'être en 2024
avec le fond vert la rénovation
énergétique en particulier certains
écoles est encore plus au cœur des
préoccupations du gouvernement et des
élus début mai 2023 c'est 105 projets de
rénovation énergétique qui concernaient
des écoles dans 81 qui incluaient les
travaux d'isolation 72 projets de
changement de système de chauffage c'est
20 millions d'euros d'aides du fond vert
qui sont mobilisés sur ces 105 premiers
projets et qui permettent un gain
énergétique total de 16 millions de
kilowattheure d'énergie finale par an
au delà des 2 milliards d'euros sur
cette seule année 2023 de l'engagement
pris par la première ministre de
poursuivre en 2024 se font essentiel aux
collectivités c'est surtout la méthode
qui change il s'agit d'un fond à la main
des territoires au plus près du couple
élu local et préfet ce n'est pas un
hasard si le millième dossier qui vient
d'être validé au titre du fond vert
concerne des dossiers de rénovation
énergétique du groupe scolaire et du
réfectoire de la commune de Chavenay
dans les Yvelines la preuve est faite du
succès de ce fond notamment pour aider
les collectivités territoriales à
poursuivre et amplifier leurs actions
pour la transition écologique il s'agit
de répondre au plus près des besoins et
des pratiques des élus locaux avec sa
pérennisation en 2024 nous engageons
aussi une visibilité plus réelle que les
élus attendent le gouvernement ses
partenaires publics comme privés les
élus locaux se sont fortement engagés
dans la voie de la rénovation du bâti
scolaire avec volontarisme et
responsabilité nous avons pris ensemble
la mesure des obstacles qui peuvent
persister sur leur chemin donc j'ai pas
les ordres de grandeur que je veux vous
rappeler qui n'étaient pas dans mon
propos liminaire je rappelle que d'ici
plus DETR c'est 2 milliards et le fond
vert de milliards donc en 2023 c'est 4
milliards on a doublé les montants
d'investissement et que la rénovation
thermique de nos énergétiques et
thermique de nos écoles elles entrent à
la fois et elle relève à la fois de la
décision de la DETR et où du fond vert
donc là je vous ai plus particulièrement
parlé de ce nouveau fond en 2023 mais
malgré tout
la DETR et la décile peuvent accompagner
des projets de rénovation ce qui n'est
pas non plus dans ces propos liminaires
mais vous le savez tous c'est à quel
point évidemment cette rénovation
thermique elle est vertueuse pour la
qualité et le confort de nos enfants
dans les écoles elle est vertueuse pour
la transition écologique mais les
vertueuse pour nos finances de nos
collectivités parce que génère des
économies et c'est tout le sens si si
vous voulez en parler on pour en parler
du tiers financement qui permet de payer
ses remboursements matières
d'investissement si tenter que on ait
besoin de la collectivités besoin
d'emprunt par les économies qui sont
faites en fonctionnement sur la base
d'un bureau d'étude qui fait un calcul
et qui dit un compte les travaux seront
fait vous allez économiser tant de
kilowattheure et donc à un prix moyen de
l'énergie de temps vous pouvez mettre
tant dans vos remboursements d'emprunt
et là c'est la Caisse des Dépôts c'est
le cerema qui qui propose des choses sur
ce tiers financement mais ensuite j'ai
quelques éléments pour répondre à votre
vos questions madame leur rapporteur je
voulais que j'enchaîne avant qu'on parte
dans le dialogue
donc
vous nous interrogez sur le fait que sur
les 51 51 000 écoles collèges lycée
seulement 14% répondent aux normes basse
consommation
et comment vont être choisis les 10000
bâtiments qui seront aidés par ce
nouveau plan
quelques éléments et puis on pourra
aussi échanger de façon plus informelle
l'objectif du programme est de permettre
l'émergence d'une dynamique territoriale
par
identification de projets modèles nous
appuyons cette logique d'émulation et de
développement des filières par le
terrain et nous saluons cette démarche
la banque des territoires a choisi
d'accompagner 10 000 projets scolaires
ayant pour objet commun au moins 40%
d'économies d'énergie c'est 10000
projets appelés par la banque des
territoires projets totem permettront de
montrer que la rénovation énergétique du
patrimoine scolaire est réalisable
efficace et mobilisatrice
ces projets sont identifiés par les
directions régionales de la banque des
territoires ou via des partenaires
locaux territoriaux une charte définira
les critères attendus pour les projets
éducs rénov fin 2023 mais d'ores et déjà
il faudra et je peux vous dire que le
projet totem soit exemplaire je l'ai
déjà dit les moins 40 % d'économie
d'énergie innovant dans les matériaux
les procédés les usages ou la
concertation opérée par les élus locaux
donc exemplaire innovantes et efficace
modèle adapté concerté reproductible
dans un territoire équivalent 200 totems
rénov seront déployés en
2023 ce sont des projets emblématiques
exemplaires et reproductible dans
d'autres territoires il servent
d'inspiration
pour les autres collectivités
territoriales donc le premier totem est
du rénov et l'école maternelle j
Quatremer à Villetaneuse dans le 93
donc il est proposé par la direction
régionale de la banque des territoires
Île-de-France c'est un prêt de 4
millions d'euros il y a l'appui de la
SEM
départementale de la préfecture et du
département
40% des économies d'énergie et label HPE
matériaux biosourcés c'est de la fibre
de bois qui a été choisie un chauffage
en géothermie
confort d'été pour le confort d'été toi
végétalisé qui a été choisi confort
d'usage et projet pédagogiques une cour
végétalisée une qualité de l'air et
sonore
qui est prise en compte dans le projet
un chantier un faible nuisant avec 80%
des déchets valorisés bon c'est juste à
titre d'exemple ce premier totem est
durénov dans le 93 voilà pour je pense
les deux premières questions vous
m'aviez dit que vous me poseriez la 3
après moi je vous propose
de m'adapter à la façon dont vous
souhaitez procéder madame la rapporteur
monsieur le Président je vous remercie
juste quelques précisions parce que là
vous nous indiquez qu'il y a déjà un
projet qui est cofinancé cette équatter
un appel à projet qui a été fait en
amont comment uniquement il a été
identifié et les 200 premiers projets
sont-ils déjà fléchés ou pas
même quand on parle de santé on dit que
les projets qui marchent je les ai vu
sur le territoire c'est ceux qui émanent
des collectivités donc ça peut
surprendre sur certaines politiques
publiques comme l'éducation mais là on
est sur compétence municipales ou sur
compétences intercommunale on vient
mettre un certain nombre d'atouts autour
on vient mettre de l'argent en
investissement mais au départ c'est pas
nous qui choisissons c'est le projet qui
est porté alors le serema apporte toute
l'ingénierie il y a une fiche tiers
financement dans le céréma et rénovation
des écoles que je vous invite à regarder
et le maire qui n'a pas la capacité à
faire l'ingénierie de ce projet pour
qu'il soit recevable alors on ne sait
pas un appel à projet mais il y a quand
même des critères que je vous ai donné
et il faudra remplir ces critères plus
répondre à une charte comme je vous l'ai
dit et donc ce projet qui a été on va
dire
identifié par la direction régionale de
la banque des territoires parce qu'à mon
avis il devait travailler précédemment
dessus et ils ont considéré que le
projet rentré et pouvait servir de
projet totem pour faire en sorte que on
puisse illustrer comme je l'ai fait là
le propos et le rendre moins théorique
[Musique]
et sinon les dossiers n'est pas éligible
de plus les délais de réponse sont très
courts cela pose un problème réel aux
petites collectivités
territoriales qui ne dispose pas des
moyens techniques et humain suffisants
comment pourrait-on améliorer ou
faciliter l'accès aux aides financières
les territoires ruraux nécessitent aussi
un traitement différencié pour
construire leur projet je vous remercie
merci madame la sénatrice donc trois
questions le guide qui est mis par le
ministère de l'Éducation le montage des
dossiers qui nécessite de l'ingénierie
et en fait la troisième qui touche au
fond vert mais je commence par la fin en
fait dans le fond vert comme vous le
savez il y a des fonds dédiés à
l'ingénierie
donc en fait le maire qui porte un
projet de rénovation de son école il
peut commencer par solliciter des fonds
du fond vert en ingénierie mais je n'ai
pas fini ils le savent pas ils le savent
pas je vous le dis je sais pas comment
le dire parce que je le dis je rencontre
50 à 70 mères toutes les semaines là je
vais à Marseille la fin de la semaine
toutes mes vidéos je demande au préfet
de réunir des maires je mesure à quel
point on a du mal
donc voilà alors
une boîte à outils
en gros communication comment on fait
savoir mère prochaine newsletter parce
que voilà moi j'écris par les
newsletters au maire mais c'est pas
certaines qui la regardent ils en
reçoivent 15000 je sais pas comment
procéder je sais pas comment procéder et
je pense que le meilleur moyen c'est
vous les sénateurs et sénatrices
franchement franchement vous les voyez
quand vous rentrez dans vos départements
donc cette boîte à outils en fait c'est
un document de la banque des territoires
contre vous Marie-Christine
bon à la banque des territoires mais sur
le site de la banque des territoires
probablement mais en tout cas on va on
va vouloir l'envoyer
donc c'est la boîte à outils et donc en
fait on voit je vais pas vous les lisser
tous parce que c'est écrit petit il y a
si il y a 6 briques la première brique
elle s'intitule accompagnement
personnalisé un appui personnalisé par
nos équipes et du rénov d'où de la bande
des territoires ils sont vraiment très
très actifs sur le sujet de la
rénovation des économes de flux dédiés à
l'éducation via acté
ah trop bien donc des économes de flux
dédiés à l'éducation voilà que tu es
plus OK et ensuite voilà expertise via
nos partenariats mais c'est eux qui
donnent donc un peu tout leurs outils la
banque des territoires mais moi je pense
que quand même le réflexe ça doit être
le fond vert qui agit en investissement
et en ingénierie
sous réserve que le projet relève de la
transition écologique donc là il faut
vraiment le faire savoir au-delà de ce
que la banque des territoires propose
vous savez que aujourd'hui ils ont plus
de secrétaire non plus il y a plus de
secrétaire de mairie donc il se retrouve
tout seul il se retrouve tout seul donc
c'est pour ça que je sais pas comment on
pourrait améliorer le système parce que
pour moi c'est bon un bon système mais
voilà comment on peut avancer sur ce
genre de dossier quand vous avez 800
habitants vous avez plus de secrétaire
de mairie et que vous êtes tout seul et
que vous recevez des mails à ça pour
recevoir des mails on en reçoit mais eux
ils ont pas le temps de faire le tri oui
ce que je voulais vous proposer parce
que j'ai pas le guide de l'éducation
qu'elle vous faites référence donc j'ai
entendu parler je n'ai pas lu
personnellement s'il n'y a pas de
référence effectivement aux différents
types de matériaux par territoire si la
différenciation dans le cadre de cette
rénovation domative n'est pas dedans moi
je prends l'engagement de tenter parce
qu'on peut pas tout quand on est au
gouvernement mais au moins de la menthe
des traits dessus de la Mandé dans un
délai raisonnable mais on va dire deux
mois peut-être avant fin juillet il ne
faut pas à mon avis trop longtemps pour
y mettre une page complémentaire et qui
soit
on va dire plus concrète si tantex je
reviendrai vers monsieur le Président
Madame la rapporteur sur ce sujet pour
dire si oui ou non on peut amander ce
guide je vais interpeller mon collègue
pas peine je vais me procurer ce guide
et je vais solliciter Christophe Béchu
pour voir parce que si vous me dites que
ce guide est connu c'est là-dedans qu'il
faut qu'on écrive il est connu de ce que
vous dites
d'accord
il y en a plusieurs en fait des guides
qui sont édités par l'Éducation
nationale avec des thématiques
différentes
donc en fonction il y a quelque chose
autour des cours d'école il y a quelque
chose autour des bâtiments également et
ça s'appelle le guide du bâti scolaire
et c'est porté par la cellule de bâties
scolaire de l'éducation nationale
bien je vais passer la parole à notre
collègue Monique et Margot qui a une
question plusieurs questions
là de à ce stade là bon parce que des
documents je pense que les mères en
reçoivent etc pourquoi ne faites pas
l'inverse c'est-à-dire que vous avoir un
numéro vert
un numéro vert ou les maires qui sont
isolés pourrait poser ces questions là
pour savoir où ils peuvent trouver les
renseignements etc faisons l'inverse
communiquant en disant
voilà contactez tel numéro et vous aurez
des informations pour
parce que c'est vrai qu'on coule sous
les mains qui n'ont pas de secrétaire de
mairie etc moi je crois qu'il faut voir
ça différemment on a trop de
sollicitations et de documents moi je
reviens sur
autre chose c'est sur aussi une
suggestion là il y a eu une proposition
de loi sur le tiers financement avec les
partenaires privés qui venaient adoptés
et il existe déjà du tiers financement
avait la Caisse des Dépôts mais il
présente certaines limites selon les
interlocuteurs que j'ai eu et pourquoi
ne pas valoriser l'existant en
réajustant ce dispositif qu'on appelle
intracting vous voyez un truc hyper
français comment un maire peut-il savoir
intracting ce que ça veut dire
voilà
parlons français ou je ne sais pas
donnons une autre aide appellation elle
se termine là la suggestion qui était à
la Caisse des Dépôts parce que un
réajustement simplement réajustement
ouvrir et peut-être ce dispositif aux
petites communes et voilà ça c'est aussi
une suggestion et également si vous
permet d'avoir la parole donc je
continue au delà de la problématique de
problèmes de financement les
collectivités ont souvent du mal à
trouver des artisans formés aux nouveaux
critères écologiques par exemple ne
peut-on pas envisager des mesures pour
renforcer la formation
dans ce domaine voilà trois suggestions
merci madame la sénatrice alors sur le
sujet du numéro vert
oui c'est vous c'est logique que vous
posez la question pourquoi pas mais en
fait les choix que nous faisons sur ce
sujet comme sur d'autres c'est de
diriger nos mères vers les acteurs du
territoire que sont le préfet ou la DDT
mais voyez les services de l'État s'il
ne répondent pas faut nous le dire moi
je peux vous dire j'en suis à 66
départements j'ai 66 visites de terrain
50 départements j'ai vu 50 préfet ils
sont d'une réactivité et ils sont passés
dans de on va dire de posture de
contrôle qu'ils gardent parce que ils
sont les garants que le droit est
respecté dans les collectivités mais ils
sont incroyablement force de proposition
donc et quand je les sollicite en tout
cas et quand je les vois agir et ce que
j'entends la première phrase du 1er mai
qui me pose une question quand je vais à
la rencontre de 60 pairs c'est tout de
suite pour me dire tout bien qu'il pense
des services de l'État malgré les petits
effectifs et la réduction des effectifs
enfin voilà donc moi j'ai envie de vous
dire Caisse des Dépôts on voit bien que
ce sujet du financement de
l'investissement pour la rénovation du
bâtis scolaire c'est quand même la
Caisse des dépôts qui se les approprié
donc le directeur régional le directeur
départemental l'interlocuteur du maire
dans la banque des dépôts il doit se
déplacer là aussi vous m'interpeller si
l'interlocuteur de la banque des dépôts
ne vient pas dans la commune quand il
est appelé donc ça me semble la
meilleure chose ensuite DDT service de
l'État
plutôt que d'après un numéro vert parce
que qu'est-ce qu'on va faire derrière
numéro vert on va mettre des opérateurs
partout en France 35000 m donc on va
avoir des gens qui vont pas forcément
avoir la réponse donc vous voyez là on a
des gens qui savent à l'échelle du
département qui sont les préfets les
services de l'État et les et les testons
cela enfin pourquoi pas moi je n'écarte
rien mais dans un deuxième temps si on
arrive à faire savoir qui doivent
appeler préfet et et quasi dépôt et puis
vous me disiez il y avait une troisième
entité non appeler
oui
ensuite sur le tir financement
ligne tracking
terre financement je pense que le
montage il est fait par la Caisse des
Dépôts
c'est un dispositif financier innovant
qui consiste à réaliser des travaux de
performance énergétique avec un temps de
retour de 13 ans voilà ça c'est la
définition mais en fait je sais pas
pourquoi vous avez retenu ce terme c'est
bien mais en fait ça c'est le principe
le socle de ce qu'on appelle le tiers
financement c'est-à-dire même 13 ans je
trouve que la banque des territoires
elle peut faire mieux faut qu'elle aille
jusqu'à 25 pour que les loyers soient
faibles et pour que justement soit
certains qu'on finance les
remboursements de l'emprunt par les
économies que l'on fait financières liés
à la rénovation du bâtiment en tout cas
moi je le tire financement je l'ai
compris c'est moi qui portait le texte
au Sénat c'est Christophe moi je l'ai
porté à l'Assemblée c'est vrai que il
s'est passé à l'unanimité aussi à
l'Assemblée et le principe est séduisant
après il faut voir dans sa mise en
oeuvre comment le maire comprend cela
comment il accepte de s'endetter avec un
remboursement hypothétique sur une
hypothétique économique je connais
beaucoup de maires il y a une énorme
prudence donc il faut observer moi je
suis emballé par cette proposition je
pense qu'il faut y aller enfin il faut
être vigilant sur comment ils embarquent
et comment la Caisse des Dépôts n'essaye
pas de les ramener de 25 de 20 à 13 ans
ou 12 ans qui finalement une capacité
que les banques peuvent faire toutes les
banques alors que la Caisse des Dépôts
elle doit pouvoir accompagner sur une
durée plus longue et sur les artisans
formés pas plus tard qu'il y a 15 jours
la première ministre qui met la dernière
main à son document de planification
écologique et on la voit à Christophe
Béchu quasi tous les mois là depuis 6
mois sur tous les champs de la
transition écologique et vous allez voir
quand elle va sortir sa planification
tout a été travaillé en termes de quels
objectifs quels moyens et quel
calendrier pour faire ces économies dans
tous les champs l'agriculture tout y est
la rénovation des bâtiments
et donc on est resté pas moins de 45
minutes sur le sujet il y a pas
d'artisans
formés il y en a très très peu donc on a
saisi elle a saisi Carole Grandjean sur
tous les centres d'apprentissage pour
que émergent très rapidement des
filières qui forment des jeunes à la
construction en bâtiment avec la
transition écologique au cœur moi j'ai
moi-même inauguré une licence pro dans
un lycée au fin fond de l'Ariège qui
s'intitule transition écologique et
processus industriel quelque chose comme
ça donc et là tout de suite en elle a
été validée en mai en juin ils avaient
déjà les 30 gamins pour remplir la promo
tellement partout en France ils sont
venus au fin fond de l'Ariège pourquoi
parce que les industriels ont vraiment
besoin de ça là notre filière de la
construction elle a absolument besoin de
ça donc sauf que oui on va pas y arriver
tout de suite il faut monter des
formations ensuite comment organiser
donc là on a saisi la chambre des
métiers de l'artisanat et la chambre et
les chambres de commerce et l'industrie
pour essayer de voir comment eux
repèrent les acteurs de la construction
qui ont embarqué
ces critères parce que beaucoup vous en
parle mais peu ont des vraies
réalisations surtout sur le choix des
matériaux
et donc vous pointez un point auquel je
ne peux que souscrire simplement je vous
rassure sur le fait que on en a
conscience et on travaille à ma
connaissance de ce qui s'est dit dans
cette réunion auprès de la première
ministre sur monter des formations
importantes à partir de septembre
donc des bacs pro dans des BTS et dut
mais aussi des CAP
et on essaye
peut-être je pourrais pas parler de la
belle mais de voir comment on peut
repérer mettre à la disposition des élus
sur un site toutes les entreprises qui
sont considérées comme étant
écologiquement responsable et qui ont
des critères écologiques avérés avec des
avec des preuves à l'appui donc oui en
manque d'artisans d'une façon générale
déjà et plus forte raison d'artisans
formés
merci madame la Présidente avant de
passer la parole à mes collègues
j'aurais dire que nous avons auditionné
la fédération nationale du bâtiment tant
au niveau national au niveau
départemental je pense en particulier la
Meurthe-et-Moselle qui nous a garanti
que les entreprises seraient répondre
madame delfabro et ensuite Madame De
Marco
sourire répond
je garantis ce que c'est un peu
contraire à ce que j'entends sur le
terrain
Véronique
concernant ce fameux dispositif
intrating
je reviens dessus parce que voilà en
réalité si vous fait cette proposition
c'est parce que lors des auditions
céréma flamme etc j'ai repris contact
avec la responsable de flammes des
allèles des agences locales de l'énergie
parce que j'avais trouvé ces propos très
intéressants et c'est elle qui m'a
suggéré et vous pourriez éventuellement
la recevoir elle avait des propositions
à faire pour justement revoir ce
dispositif vers les petites communes
voilà c'est simplement le revoir pour
l'adapter aux petites communes je
pourrais vous donner ses coordonnées
éventuellement c'est la directrice la
responsable de flammes voilà donc
c'était voilà parce que ça peut être
pertinent il avait aussi d'autres
propositions et
ça peut être des pistes
je finis
moi je voulais juste rebondir par
rapport à ce qu'a dit Monique par
rapport à son numéro vert en fait le
problème que nous avons mère quand on a
36000 mails et quand on n'a pas le sujet
en tête les mails on les voit pas et
quand le projet surgit on ne sait pas où
aller chercher donc c'est pas un
problème de données de l'information
c'est le problème alors le numéro vert
c'est peut-être une solution il y en a
d'autres c'est le problème au moment où
on a enfin le moment où on a le problème
comment trouver le bonheur interlocuteur
c'est ça en fait l'idée c'est c'est le
fait qu'on ait noyé de mail et
on les lie mais voilà
juste pour partager avec vous ma petite
expérience
de ces 9 derniers mois mais il y a
quelques réflexes que je n'avais pas
quand j'étais mère la NTS en étant
ants.gouv aide aux élus les quelques qui
vont me disent à quel point on y
retrouve tout donc déjà avoir le réflexe
on a créé une agence
le Sénat fait un rapport quelques
examéliorations on les a tous repris la
dès maintenant on a corrigé ce qu'il
nous demandait de corriger donc
ants.gouv.fr c'est déjà un lieu ensuite
si on veut chercher des financements ça
mange pas de pain d'aller sur le site de
la Caisse des Dépôts banque des
territoires banque des territoires ants
on trouve beaucoup beaucoup de choses il
y a guère que la DGF quand on veut
parler de finance locale donc là il faut
appeler mon cabinet et là je vais
appeler sur la DGCL pour pour vous pour
vous répondre et je le fais très
régulièrement à l'invitation des
sénateurs de répondre sur des sujets de
finance locale et sinon surtout ce qui
est aide sur le réflexe ça doit être la
NTS
la
ncts c'est les titres sécurisés je suis
dessus non non c'était surtout et la
banque des territoires et surtout le
sous-préfet
ce préfet ou le préfet
je passe par Madame Céline de Brunin
j'ai participé madame la ministre à
l'audition du directeur de la NT il y a
quelques jours par la commission du
développement durable du Sénat
et
l'écho que donnait nos collègues c'était
pas tout à fait que vous ayez enfin que
line c'était est reprise les
préconisations que nous avons faites
dans le rapport que nous avons rendu il
y a encore beaucoup beaucoup de chemin à
parcourir je pense et les élus locaux
ont toujours énormément de mal à se
retrouver dans ces méandres de
dispositifs divers et variés qui qui
sont pas forcément à la main des
communes et des plus petites communes
parce que la limite une grosse
collectivité qui a des tas de services
une ingénierie elle va toujours finir
par trouver où s'adresser mais on pense
là évidemment aux petites et moi je
voudrais me permettre si vous m'y
autorisez madame la ministre à revenir à
la première une des premières questions
que vous a posé notre rapporteur
c'est est-ce que on peut attendre de
l'État sur ce sujet des efforts
spécifiques ou est-ce que ce sont des
redéploiements de crédit parce que vous
avez évoqué la DETR vous avez évoqué la
décile on pourrait dire que le fond vert
c'est quelque chose d'un peu nouveau
mais qui préexister quand même à aux
annonces concernant la rénovation du
bâti scolaire et j'ai lu comme nous tous
ici le président Macron dans Le Parisien
qui a dit en substance on va mettre de
l'argent sur la rénovation énergétique
vous avez évoqué 5 milliards deux par an
les auditions qu'on a fait ici disent 40
milliards au total
et donc y compris si on utilisait toute
la DETR et toute la DSI et tout le fond
vert ça ne suffirait pas
en sachant qu'on est dans un contexte où
les collectivités ont dû faire face
les coûts de l'énergie qui était en
explosion et qui précisément je pense
les les amènent à réfléchir à ces
rénovations parce que elle souhaite
avoir des réponses de long terme
mais que leur capacité d'investissement
compte tenues des surcoûts auxquels elle
doit faire face aujourd'hui sont
extrêmement à moins de riz et donc je
pense que il y a vraiment un effort
supplémentaire à faire de la part de
l'État même si les collectivités doivent
évidemment y participer aussi parce que
sinon on
ne sera pas au niveau d'ambition qui est
attendu en la matière il me semble
je vais finir par une question aussi
parce que je rencontre ça tous les jours
je dis je rencontre des mères toutes les
semaines moi j'ai du mal si vous voulez
je vais vous dire la réponse c'est non
en 2023
parce que j'aime bien moi dire les
choses comme elles sont aujourd'hui on
met 4 milliards c'est pour ça que j'ai
pris la peine de vous le dire on en
mettait deux et on en met quatre et on
dit on porte un joli programme de
rénovation mais aujourd'hui tant que le
fond vert et que la décide de terre qui
aujourd'hui est consommée à
25%. il faut que les travaux démarrent
dans l'année pour qu'on puisse donner
des sous pourquoi les consommer 25%
elles valaient être à 100% la fin de
l'année bien sûr et le fond vert aussi
mais soyons réalistes c'est à dire qu'on
me demande toujours plus les sous sont
là et en fait quelle est la capacité à
agir dans nos territoires quand on voit
les problèmes de recrutement moi je
crois qu'il y a des problèmes de
recrutement de gens pour faire ces
travaux il y a un travail d'ingénierie
vous l'avez dit avant pour se poser et
avoir la manne nécessaire pour porter le
projet de rénovation de son école
attend la capacité au moins 2023 et 2024
à faire tout ce qu'il faudrait faire
vite mais le problème c'est pas que
l'État n'est pas l'argent moi je peux
vous dire vous mourrez comme première
ambassadrice quand vous avez vu sans
premier projet en émerge et vous avez vu
sur le montant que je vous ai cité
voilà
40 millions d'euros on est quasi fin
juin
40 millions d'euros ils vont me dire
qu'il me faut plusieurs argent
donc aujourd'hui ce que je veux dire
c'est que ce temps d'ingénierie bien sûr
qu'il y a tout ça à faire mais on le
fait pas comme ça donc il y a de
l'ingénierie il y a des travaux il y a
des appels d'offres à conduire et donc
l'argent le dépense il faut que les
travaux aient lieu dans l'année pour
qu'on le dépense donc bien sûr que votre
question est normal et légitime elle
m'est posé tout le temps mais avant de
me demander de l'argent consommons ce
que l'on a moi les préfets me disent il
y a des fonds que j'ai déjà délivrés un
préfet sur deux en 2022 les travaux
n'ont pas commencé j'ai bien voulu
continuer et oui il faut de l'énergie il
faut des services dans les pour conduire
il faut faire les marchés publics donc
juste ce que je veux vous dire vous qui
êtes des gens raisonnables les sénateurs
et sénatrices c'est que en
investissement il y a pas de problème il
y a pas de problème aujourd'hui et que
le camp président dit on mettra de
l'argent si aujourd'hui on avait déjà
consommé nos fonds et qui avait 500
écoles ou 200 écoles qui attendaient il
nous manque de l'argent on le mettrait
on a su le faire pendant la crise c'est
un sujet majeur mais aujourd'hui
consommons déjà nos fonds sur lesquels
on s'est engagé en 2022
consomment nos fonds 2023 et là on a
déjà garanti les 2 milliards de plus en
4 milliards mais moi qui était maire et
comme beaucoup d'entre vous je veux dire
pour faire
ça prend du temps ça prend de l'énergie
madame le ministre je voudrais vous oui
mais les fonds de droit commun
la France n'est pas un pays homogène que
les départements sont différents dans
certains départements ça marche dans
d'autres départements ça marche beaucoup
moins bien parce que dans ces
départements les communes ont vu leur
autofinancement
s'écrouler s'effondrer après 13 années
de baisse ou de stagnation de la DGF
c'est la première fois ça augmente de
320 millions je crois
les marges de manœuvre de ces communes
ont une consomme pas parce qu'il y a pas
de projet en consommant pas parce qu'on
n'a pas les moyens
d'apporter la contrepartie pour arriver
à 100%. si la subvention faisait 90 % de
commune trouverait peut-être les 5%.
mais en fait on s'aperçoit que dans ce
système ce sont les plus les moins
pauvres ou les plus riches qui
consomment mes subventions parce que
elles ont la capacité de mettre en place
la contrepartie moi je plaide aussi pour
que les mais ça c'est une affaire de de
financeurs les collectivités les
départements les régions aussi pour
contiennent compte chacune des légitimes
de choisir aussi celle qui prévaut chez
elle contient une cause de la capacité
contributive des opérateurs il y a des
communes qui peuvent plus et qu'on se
retrouverait jamais les les les sous
parce que elles peuvent pas faire
c'est pour alors aimer moi je moi je ne
prête pas au tiers financement des
vertus qu'il n'a peut-être pas
nous ne faisons pas beaucoup d'illusions
non plus d'ailleurs votre ministre
monsieur Béchu a dit ne faisons pas trop
d'illusions quand même c'est un plus
mais c'est pas ça qui va régler la
question du financement ça serait ça
serait magique ainsi non mais c'est pas
une solution magique madame
ce point si vous me le permettez
monsieur le Président vraiment rappelé
que le tiers financement c'est une
expérimentation qui est sur cinq ans et
donc vous l'avez entendu dans mes propos
on va observer on va regarder
moi j'ai beaucoup confiance dans la
Caisse des Dépôts quand ils embarquent
des dispositifs ils les font fonctionner
en général on l'a vu sur action cordes
on le voit sur petite ville de demain
mais quand même je suis d'accord avec
vous il faut observer mais prenons-le
comme une expérimentation et sur le le
l'autofinancement là aussi je vois
énormément de verre et ça me vient
spontanément voilà 80% vous comprenez on
a plus rien j'ai pas encore trouvé un
maire pas trouvé un maire j'ai signé 20
courriers l'an dernier je suis arrivé
j'ai remplacé comme une cardio à partir
de début décembre je suis une vingtaine
de courrier quand la Première ministre
dit on ne laissera aucune commune au
bord du chemin 20 courrier qui
accompagne des chèques sont des communes
qui répondent à un certain nombre de
critères et qui sont en épargne nette
négative et sur lesquels on abonde on
les accompagne avec un plan de remise à
flot de leur finance et l'État est là il
y a pas de problème 20
à part ces vins chaque fois que j'ai
posé la question et je vous invite à
faire de même juste pour que vous me
disiez je l'ai fait sur 10 j'en ai eu
trois j'en ai eu 5 bon chaque fois mais
je l'ai fait allez 30 fois et j'ai
encore fait hier je sais pas qui était
avec moi une sénatrice qui m'envoie des
petits mots quand je suis dans
l'hémicycle pour me dire j'ai un maire
il est gang il peut plus et j'arrive pas
à lui expliquer la DGF etc j'avais un
collaborateur de la DGCL qui m'a
accompagné et avec la sénatrice on était
en visio avec Monsieur le Maire et donc
toujours cette question j'ai pu
d'épargne etc donc là c'est 100% de tous
ceux que j'ai interrogé
qui
quand je leur pose la question mais
juste pour information Monsieur le Maire
qu'elle était votre taux financement
quel est votre épargne net quel est
votre épargne brut votre autofinancement
de l'année 2022 j'ai tout le temps le E
Monsieur le Maire peut pas me dire vous
souvenez pas compte administrative vous
l'avez voté donc vous souvenez et là
mais là j'ai de tout j'en ai un 4
millions et demi ah oui mais comprenez
la baissé de 20% ah bah oui on est en
crise bien sûr et nous on a 3000
milliards de dettes l'état donc ce que
je veux dire c'est que oui ça baisse oui
ils ont moins de l'autofinancement mais
quand on va lundi dialoguer avec Bercy
je peux vous dire que on va entendre une
fois deux fois trois fois quelle est la
réalité la réalité c'est qu'il y a 50
milliards
de trésorerie dans les collectivités
locales
50 milliards donc oui en moyenne mais
voilà donc les mers sont d'excellents
gestionnaires ils prévoient ils
épargnent ils ont peur parce que ça
baisse oui ça baisse mais nous aussi au
niveau de l'État nos finances publiques
elles sont fragiles et donc
oui ça baisse mais les fameux 20% dont
vous parlez sur des projets qui sont
portés mon courrier il avait 300.000
euros un maire d'une commune de 1000
habitants Monsieur le Maire vous en
mettez 150 de côté je comprends mais
mettez-en 150 en financement sur un
projet de 700000 euros mais moi je vais
vous aider je vais le prendre comme
exemple pour aller chercher de l'argent
de l'État la DETR de la région est porté
moins de projet de 700000 700000 euros
j'étais pas possible pour lui mais si la
300000 euros au départ et il va les
mettre où il va les mettre de côté et
voilà et donc nous moi ce que je veux
dire c'est que les 320 millions qu'on a
mis cette année je dis pas waouh c'est
génial c'est pas parce que ça fait 13
ans qu'on avait pas augmenté la DGF que
waouh c'est génial non mais
on l'a augmenté et oui on est en crise
donc oui je ne considère pas qu'un
gouvernement serait responsable s'il
avait
comme politique publique vis-à-vis des
collectivités locales de rendre
l'inflation neutre pour les élus locaux
il y a pas d'inflation pour eux on
compense l'inflation ce qui nous a été
demandé beaucoup puis dans quel pays on
est on a 3000 milliards de dettes et
pour les maires mais il pourrait eux
fonctionner comme s'il n'y avait pas
d'inflation non c'est difficile et mais
qu'est-ce qui sont bons gestionnaires
combien m'ont dit mais moi les gymnases
j'ai éteint les gamins ils ont mis les
blousons ils ont mis des pulls et du
coup j'ai pas chauffé j'ai baissé ma
consommation ah oui mais en étant crise
donc on était en crise sanitaire là on
est en crise face à l'énergie donc
moi je me permets de vous dire ça parce
que comme je suis confronté à ça toutes
les semaines toutes les semaines et je
me rends compte que l'épargne est liée
donc quand vous me dites les petites
communes oui mais si porte des projets
raisonnables on peut les étaler moi je
milite voilà je sais que vous y tenez
beaucoup au Sénat je sais pas si on y
arrivera mais sur la plurianualité des
aides les départements font ça on doit
faire ça on doit donner de la visibilité
à nos mères en investissement
exactement
ah oui d'accord merci monsieur le
président compris
merci Madame la Ministre ma question
rejoint celle de notre collègue Céline
Brulin et je souhaitais revenir sur cet
accompagnement financier notamment sur
le fond vert parce que c'est vrai que
c'est une aide non négligeable mais sur
un département comme le mien c'est une
enveloppe 2 millions d'euros pour
l'Ardèche donc les projets sont nombreux
en terme de de transition énergétique
les objectifs et ambitieux le travail
est colossal on sait le reste à charge
enfin 80% on a dit du travail reste à
faire donc si c'est l'objectif 2030
actuellement on a beaucoup communiqué
sur le fond vert vous l'avez dit c'est
un succès vous nous avez confirmé qu'il
y aura une pérennisation 2024 donc on
est ravi mais on a beaucoup communiqué
le préfet parle beaucoup du fond vert
nous demande de communiquer sur le fond
vert et l'enveloppe est déjà consommé à
cette période de l'année et c'est vrai
qu'on a l'impression que c'est les
premiers qui ont demandé ce sont les
premiers servis donc voilà il y a
quelque chose moi ce que j'aimerais
c'est avoir cette visibilité dont vous
nous parlez tout à fait qu'il faut
envisager des aides pluri annuelles
avoir un phasage donc est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire en 2024 à quoi
ressemblera le fond vert est-ce que
c'est un peu tôt est-ce qu'on a un bilan
je sais qu'il sera pérennisé mais à
quelle hauteur parce qu'on a quand même
aussi besoin de ce projeter et d'avoir
de la visibilité c'est vrai que les
préfets les sous préfets font très bien
leur travail mais nous disent on va
accompagner les communes sur plusieurs
années il se déplace on travaille le
phasage des travaux les études qui sont
non mais c'est vrai mais à un moment
voilà on en a quand même besoin
sur le fond vert d'abord au Christophe
vichu a pris conscience il y a un mois
de l'absolu nécessité de simplifier
l'accès aux fonds
et c'est la DGALN qui gère le fond vert
c'est une direction de la nature et la
nature l'aménagement est l'environnement
qui le gère toujours avec les préfets
sacristobecheux obtenu que tout soit la
main est préfet mais avec deux circuits
différents pour nous au niveau de l'État
la DGCL pour décide etr et c'est vrai
qu'on appelle un peu de nos vœux que ça
soit aussi simple que des cils et des TR
le fond vert on a un peu de mal donc
pour l'instant Christophe a pris
conscience d'abord on avait bien
simplifié le formulaire il est assez
simple il y a 14 cases à cocher mais
tout ce qui demande derrière c'est
extrêmement lourd avec des lettres
d'engagement ce matin j'ai reçu pour mon
plus grand bonheur le monsieur le Maire
qui marche qui a marché depuis la
Gironde jusqu'à Beauvais jusqu'à chez
nous ce matin
et donc il est je l'ai reçu et il me
disait donc ben lui il démerde une
commune de 1100 habitants et il me dit
tous les dossiers j'en ai fait 14 cette
année bon et mercredi 2020 et bon il a
dit demande donc on va aller traiter
parce que il y a plein de bonnes idées
il est très constructif
mais le sujet de du fond vert et de sa
complexité il m'a dit j'en suis à 14
aussi je sais les remplir et tout c'est
moi qui le fait sa communauté trop
petite donc ça ça fait partie des choses
qui peuvent décevoir un jeune merde 40
ans qui est élu depuis deux ans et il me
dit c'est toutes ces lettres
d'engagement c'est pas tellement le fait
qu'il faille prouver
que l'on va générer des économies parce
que pour relever du fond vert il faut
prouver qu'on est on a quand même la
transition écologique au cœur du projet
donc il faut une étude qui prouve qu'on
fait des des économies d'émissions de
COD de CO2 mais ils me disent pas
tellement ça c'est toutes ces lettres
d'engagement et moi je les avais pas
avant donc il faut que je les crée donc
il y a une administration dans laquelle
on va se plonger mais je crois que les
services de Christophe échu le font
parce qu'il s'engage avant fin juin
d'avoir simplifié l'accès au fond vert
donc ça c'était l'une d'entre vous qui
avait posé la question et j'avais pas
répondu donc ça c'est c'est
il faut veiller à ce que effectivement
ça soit le cas et ensuite
[Musique]
quelle est la visibilité pour 2024
aujourd'hui à part de la simplification
je pense que l'objectif va être
équivalent et qu'on va partir toujours
sur 2 milliards en 2024 on espère plus
mais moi je vais être à table des
négociations dès lundi on va bien voir
mais voilà à minimal la première
ministre a prévu de milliards de plus en
2024 comment on va pouvoir y accéder via
des sollicitations dans les services de
l'État auprès du préfet pareil ça on
veut pas déroger à cela et il va falloir
prouver que en génère des économies
d'énergie et on essaye de maintenir
quand même un certain nombre de projets
ce qu'on va verdir un peu la DETR et la
DS
trop trop parce qu'il faut quand même
pouvoir faire un certain nombre de
d'objets autre dont on besoin nos
communes et pour que ça ne sera pas que
des projets qui ont la transition
écologique au cœur voilà mais et on va
tenir bon Christophe ça aussi
on a parlé on a beaucoup pardon j'ai
oublié j'ai oublié de mettre le micro on
a beaucoup parlé sous vous avez indiqué
5,2 milliards d'euros
par an sur la question est sur combien
d'années
sur 10 ans d'accord sur le rapport de
Marc qui date de 2020 il mentionnait 4
40 millions au total 4 millions et
préconisés 4 milliards pardon c'est trop
de chiffres pour moi
pendant 10 ans et on a aussi parlé
ingénierie est-ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire plus sur l'accompagnement en
fait des élus qui va être mis en place
sur le parcours donc qui a été présenté
je suis toujours sur le plan en fait qui
a été présenté le 9 mai sur le parcours
d'accompagnement la charte nationale
destinée à guider les projets la boîte à
idées dont on a entendu parler donc
pendant 9 mai et quelle structure pour
les piloter et également donc vous nous
avez indiqué que 105 projets
non je me trompe c'est 200 projets qui
sont déjà en cours pour 2023 sur des
projets totems et ce qui a un phasage
plus clair en fait dans le calendrier
sachant que normalement il est pour 4
ans et donc quels sont les bornes en
fait sur les quatre années à venir
avait également une question
le Président vous autorich chers
je voudrais essayer de d'être assez
réaliste sur le problème qui se pose à
une collectivité lorsqu'elle veut faire
un investissement de cette nature pour
tout le monde ici participe aux réunions
départementales des élus qui à louent la
DETR
donc ça nous donne une idée des montages
et des dossiers qui sont présentés au
service souvent de la des
sous-préfecture ou voir au service
du secrétaire général dans le pour la
Sous-Préfecture de la capitale mais la
question c'est que il faut d'abord
mettre en place le plan de financement
bon nous savons ça a été dit tout à
l'heure que les les petites communes
notamment sont en grande situation de
difficultés donc elles vont avec l'aide
de du sous-préfet généralement monter un
plan de financement et elles vont voir
ce qu'elles peuvent obtenir de
l'extérieur la première
source de financement qui est
généralement visée notamment devant
cette cet instance c'est la DETR la DETR
est délivrée donc après un avis
préfectoral et donc là dessus il n'y a
pas vraiment vétérinablement de
problèmes ensuite
vous parlez de la décide là des cils
déjà à une particularité c'est que comme
elle était souvent demandée par à la
fois les communes et les intercos dans
beaucoup d'endroits finalement c'est le
cas dans mon département on a décidé
désormais de réserver la des cils aux
interco
autre source possible de financement il
y a ce que peut apporter effectivement
le fond vert et là on trouve un obstacle
que j'ai noté à plusieurs reprises cette
année c'est que le fond vert est géré au
niveau régional par les services de la
Dréal
puis sa vie
sur les services environnementaux qui
gèrent se font vert de la même façon que
la décide est-elle à louer par les
services régionaux donc quand la
préfecture monte ses dossiers en général
elle n'a pas connaissance des décisions
par exemple si elle veut allouer de la
DETR de la décision qui a été rendue sur
la descille et sur le fond vert au
niveau régional
donc
je continue on est là
on est là au niveau
je voulais je vous l'ai expliqué tout ça
parce que pour bien voir quelles sont
les difficultés que rencontre un maire
quand il veut faire monter son dossier
le
goût non mais c'est arrivé souvent ça
arrive de moins en moins mais autrefois
ça arrivait assez souvent puis le fond
vert n'existait pas à l'époque bon et
puis il y a donc après il faut trouver
l'autofinancement pour le reste quand on
n'a pas véritablement bon actuellement
chez nous la détruire quand vous
l'obtenez c'est souvent à 30% autrefois
c'était souvent 40% mais maintenant
c'est plutôt 30%. le fond vert vient
combler une partie et il faut trouver le
financement donc tout ça pour vous dire
que la difficulté est grande pour une
collectivité qui notamment
à une dotation d'investissement qui est
réduite pratiquement à néant qui n'a pas
fiscalement la possibilité
d'autofinancer vous disiez tout à
l'heure que finalement on reçoit pas
énormément de dossiers c'est parce que
dans une commune il n'y a pas que
l'école il y a tous les autres
investissements à faire
que bien évidemment mais il faut un
moment donné que cette collectivité
choisisse l'investissement qu'elle va
demander à financer au gouvernement et
donc quand on remet tout ça avec le
niveau actuel par exemple du fond vert
dont vous disiez tout à l'heure ce qui
est exact que il est de 2 milliards par
an au niveau national je vous laisse
vous faites le calcul mesurer ce
qu'apporte sa peur présenter au niveau
des communes chez dans mon département
il y a 256 communes mais au niveau
national
[Musique]
si on rapporte cette somme au nombre de
communes et bien c'est quand même très
difficile et là je pense que vous le
disiez à MIMO mais il est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui il y a un véritable
problème d'investissement mais
précisément sur les communes les plus
pauvres parce que elles n'ont pas la
possibilité chez elle de prendre un
impôt qui puisse leur permettre après la
disparition d'un certain nombre de
fiscalités locales et bien elle ne
peuvent pas payer pour reconstruire une
école une école qui s'effondre si c'est
quelques millions d'euros je vous laisse
imaginer quel est le dilemme pour le
maire voilà ce que je voulais vous dire
ça me paraît important de ramener ça à
ce qui est fait sur le terrain
je commence par vous donner quelques
éléments de réponse monsieur le sénateur
d'abord je vous ai dit 2 milliards d'ici
plus de termes mes cousez bien en tête
que c'est autour d'amis hier 5 la DETR
et 500 millions la décision donc
om la DR autre ordre de grandeur
j'aimerais bien que vous y en tête et là
depuis 10 ans juste doublé donc les
petites communes en réalité que je
défends c'est mon portefeuille aussi
mais voilà donc une DETR qui a doublé
une de TR qui représente 3/4 de
l'investissement public des sites plus
DETR
et donc
vous dites que la dot est bien géré
parce qu'elle est gérée à la maille
départementale et que il y a une
commission qui répartit ce montant de
DETR et vous dites la décile
elle est gérée à l'échelle de la région
et Monsieur
le Directeur me rappelait que on a signé
une circulaire il y a pas longtemps pour
demander à ce que le plus possible la
décide soit déconcentrée au niveau
départemental mais avoir en tête que ce
n'est qu'un cas de ces 2 milliards
là-dessus ensuite quand vous me dites on
la consacre aux interco moi je vous
assure que j'ai fait le tour ça doit
être le cas dans quelques départements
mais
excusez-moi mais ça c'est une décision
qui au départ local oui je l'avais
jamais vu ça
mais c'est incroyable mais ça veut dire
qu'une grande ville
ça veut dire qu'une grande ville
et elle peut pas elle a pas accès à
grandes villes très grandes villes alors
des très grandes villes qui n'ont pas
accès à la det
E
effectivement il fallait
donc
j'ai pas de réponse
si ce n'est le fait que ce qu'on
constate c'est que le nombre de communes
qui portent des projets augmente très
significativement donc ça ça explique le
fait qu'on soit passé d'une moyenne de
40 % il y a quelques années à 30 et les
maires les plus habitués à avoir
beaucoup de TR chaque année j'en ai vu
ce week-end qui me disait moi ça fait
cinq mandats je vois ma DETR fondre en
pourcentage chaque fois il disait aux
collègues mère qui était qui était là
vous les les maires vous demandiez pas
autrefois donc mer qui était un peu
entrepreneur qui portait des projets il
avait beaucoup de TR parce que se
répartissait entre moins de commune mais
là il y en a de plus en plus qui
demandent et donc bien que le fond vert
soit venu doubler les montants
d'investissement malgré tout c'est vrai
qu'on reste en moyenne à 30% et qu'on
essaye de faire en sorte que les projets
soient des etr soit DSI soit fond vert
et que rares sont les projets moi j'en
ai pas vu récemment mais qui relève de
de fond donc je partage votre votre
constat
tout en rappelant que la DETR c'est
encore un milliard 5 et que voilà
ensuite vous dites plus d'impôts pour
avoir des marges de manœuvre ça c'est je
veux et je veux pas revenir sur la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation
suppression d'un CVAE c'est un certain
nombre de décision qui ont leurs
avantages et qui ont leurs inconvénients
et qui effectivement enlèvent la
possibilité aux maires de
augmenter sa fiscalité pour se donner
des marges de manœuvre supplémentaire
donc
voilà donc moi je suis tout à fait prête
monsieur le sénateur a travaillé
quelques cas avec vous sur votre
département
et même je vais regarder l'Ardèche on va
regarder
12 millions d'euros de DETR
s'il y a que 2 millions de fonds verts
il y a quand même 12000 vous avez dit
deux millions pour le fond vert
voilà et 12 millions pour la DETR
il y a beaucoup enfin on avait travaillé
en commission de etr beaucoup de travaux
ciblés pour la rénovation des réseaux
pour répondre à la question de Madame la
rapporteur sur
l'accompagnement en fait
l'accompagnement dans la conduite des
projets donc là j'ai quelques éléments
c'est pardon
d'accord toujours notre banque des
territoires pour éduquer rénov et c'est
vraiment le nom du programme de la
banque des territoires et ce programme
prévoit trois choses 1 la mise en place
d'un parcours d'accompagnement
territorialisé permettant un suivi de
bout en bout des projets de manière
unifiée au sein du programme du
diagnostic avec les élus et les services
techniques au financement de projet donc
ce quand je vous dis tout à l'heure
aller chercher de l'ingénierie dans le
fond vert parce que il y a des budgets
ingénierie dans le fond vert ça reste
vrai mais si on parle de la rénovation
thermique d'une école
rentrons dans le parcours
d'accompagnement territorialisé que la
banque des territoires met en avant et
si je vous assure mon cabinet croule un
peu parce que il bosse beaucoup mais
rien si vous en rencontrez des
difficultés un mail chez nous pour
comprendre et moi je passe deux coups de
fil en et vous allez voir que les gens
vont être réactifs aujourd'hui on n'est
pas inondé de gens qui nous disent que
la banque du territoire ou les préfets
ou les réponses sont pas données dans
les territoires donc parce que ils
savent que si on remonte au ministère
cette réactivité elle vous éduque tout
ne va pas bien mais à moins mais au
moins qu'on réponde aux questions et
qu'on traite les difficultés donc ce
parcours d'accompagnement que met en
avant
territorialiser la banque des
territoires moi je vous invite à dire au
maire de s'en saisir voilà et ils disent
qu'ils accompagnaient à faire un
diagnostic avec les élus et ils font
aussi des recommandations avec les
services techniques sur le financement
du projet derrière
très intéressant deuxièmement
l'élaboration je vous en ai parlé mais
je vous ai dit qu'elle allait aboutir en
fin d'année de la Charte nationale qui
comprend l'ensemble de critères pour
guider des projets de rénovation alors
évidemment il faut viser ceux qui
portent 40% d'économies d'énergie il
faut utiliser des procédés de rénovation
favorisant l'innovation etc ce que je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure c'est charte
sera travaillé avec l'ensemble des
partis prenantes au programme
dont pourquoi le Mendji dans le
ministère de la transition écologique et
des cohésion territoriales mais aussi de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
donc conjointe par est en train d'être
travaillé cette charte et elle est
prévue pour la fin de l'année 2023
donc là si on travaille à le ministère
de l'Éducation l'engagement que j'ai
pris tout à l'heure peut-être rentrer
là-dedans et on va pas pouvoir répondre
à enfin juillet comme j'aimerais il va
falloir attendre descendre trop tard
on va voir parce que là pourquoi fin de
20023 pour écrire une charte mais bon
donc cette charte elle est quand même
fondamentale parce qu'elle répond à vos
questions qui est de dire quelles sont
les critères comment on s'y prend et les
200 pourquoi 200 en fait c'est 200
premiers c'est pas de 200 que nous
allons décider mais il faut qu'il
réponde à ces critères l'accès simplifié
à la boîte outil dédiée qui est réalisé
que je vous ai montré tout à l'heure
qu'on retrouve sur le site de la Caisse
des la Caisse des Dépôts les tailles ces
opérateurs partenaires du programme et
du Renov participeront à l'orientation
et au suivi du programme à travers son
comité stratégique qui se réunit pour la
première fois avant la fin du mois de
juin et
je vous ai cité aussi le séréma qui joue
un rôle en accompagnement à la demande
de la banque des territoires de la
Caisse des Dépôts un rôle dans
l'ingénierie de ces projets est-ce que
ça répond à peu près à votre question
merci madame la ministre
effectivement en fait la clé d'entrée
pour une commune qui a une question sur
une rénovation d'école c'est la banque
des territoires
c'est le point d'entrée il se charge
ensuite en fonction de là où en est le
projet de créer le parcours qui va bien
soit voilà soit juste le financement
parce que le projet est très avancé soit
line générique si le projet on est en
bas le bullement voilà donc la clé
d'entrée la banque des territoires et
quand on parlait de boîte à outils tout
à l'heure il y a on entendait la NCT
hier qui nous a parlé également que de
d'une sorte de boîte à outils mais qui
était solution élue ou un certain nombre
d'élus faisait remonter des projets et
qui pouvait effectivement être une une
sorte de boîte à idées donc tout ça si
ça pouvait être réuni dans une un même
pôle ce serait parfait je vous remercie
moi j'en ai terminé avec mes questions
je
sur solution d'élus donc c'est quelque
chose qu'on a co-construit avec merci
beaucoup monsieur président avec
Christophe Béchu et la NCT donc il n'y a
qu'un lieu qu'un lieu dans lequel vous
pouvez inviter les mères soit à partager
une expérience réussie et d'entrée sur
la première page
solutions
soit vous partagez une expérience et on
vous envoie un photographe on vous
envoie vidéaste pour pouvoir filmer le
projet donner envie à quelqu'un de
reproduire ce qui a bien marché sur
votre commune donc si le maire a envie
de ça sinon vous pouvez aller chercher
des expériences qui ont tout été initié
dans les territoires par exemple une
maison de santé qui a été portée par une
collectivité vous savez des critères la
santé le sport rénovation patrimoniale
et vous avez tout un tas de solutions
d'élus rien à voir avec l'autre sujet de
la banque des territoires et de la
rénovation d'école là c'est juste une
plateforme qui puissance toutes les
bonnes pratiques on veut pouvoir
partager et reproduire et c'est tout et
ensuite le parcours pour rénovation et
je pense que quand on aura des bonnes
pratiques pour des rénovations d'école
ensuite ça ira dans solutions d'élus
mais là on y va tous seuls on parcours
on met ses critères et on trouve des
idées pour ce que l'on veut faire par
contre si on veut se faire accompagner
là c'est la variété merci monsieur le
Président je vous en prie vous je l'ai
dit dans mes propos liminaires nous
avons reçu quelques
1300 témoignages d'élus
je vais vous dire très sincèrement que
les témoignages qui non seulement nous
n'ont pas dit du bien ni de la banque
des territoires ni du cerema parce qu'il
les connaissent pas il y en a pas eu
et donc construire une réponse sur la
base de structure
quasiment inconnu en tout cas dans le
monde rural en particulier c'est faire
un sacré Paris je disais tout à l'heure
il y a des départements qui sont
organisés en mettant en place une des
agences des techniques départementales
il y en a beaucoup et ça marche bien et
je pense que
que
si le cerema est si la
NCT et la banque des territoires veulent
être utilisés faudrait que ça veutisse
d'abord dans les départements où il n'y
a pas
d'organisation de l'ingénierie
prioritairement parce que c'est pas la
peine d'aller faire de la concurrence là
où la solution existe déjà qui plus
lorsque la solution est publique mais
j'avais une question qui paraît
anecdotique mais qui est importante pour
les communes qu'elle concerne vous dites
alors à propos des 10000 projets qu'il
fallait qu'il génère moins 40% de
d'énergie
c'est c'est un chiffre qui n'est pas un
chiffre biblique on sait d'où il vient
mais celles qui ont déjà fait un effort
par le passé on a passé sont tout assez
récent
c'est difficile de faire 40% encore donc
il faudra attirer l'attention des
décideurs
sur la période d'apprendre en compte
quand on mesure cet effort parce que
sinon c'est la prime mon mauvais élève
dire que 40% quand j'ai jamais rien fait
je fais pas
et ceux qui ont fait
quelques temps avant l'effort et il m'a
ils sont pas payer de retour quoi
je pense que il faudrait prendre la au
compte le précédent pour les
collectivités concernées je vous renvoie
vers la banque des territoires parce que
il peut y avoir des exceptions
Marie-Christine me disait que il peut y
avoir des cas dans lesquels ils seront
plein à prendre en compte le fait qu'on
a déjà baissé de vin depuis 3 ans en
changeant les huisseries je sais pas
certains de choses et puis ils veulent
poursuivre leur travail de rénovation il
reste encore une tranche mais on va
baisser que de 20 parce qu'on a déjà
baissé de 20 et donc
ils peuvent être ouverts à ça je vous
dis pas que
c'est la porte grand ouverte mais en
tout cas elle me disait que il faut le
laisser à l'arbitrage de la Caisse des
Dépôts si vraiment dans les trois
dernières ou quatre dernières années un
gros travail qui a été fait financé sans
aide ou avec des mais
pas dans ce cas de ce dispositif pour
aller chercher les 20% d'économie
complémentaire je pense qu'ils seront
ouverts la banque des dépôts à l'entend
était appartenait des grandes
collectivités parce que c'est
intéressant historiquement d'abord au
projet
d'intérêt régional ou départemental et
donc du coup les communes de petite
taille ne s'y ne s'y retourne pas vers
elle il faudra du temps pour que les
habitudes changent et la banque des
territoires
elle ne fait pas de subventions elles
prête et les communes ont le souci aussi
de ne pas trop s'endetter parce qu'ils
savent que au moment où arrivent les
élections c'est un critère qui parle
beaucoup aux électeurs le tout
d'endettement et
en cela on peut pas le reprocher
d'imiter l'état ils ne peuvent pas mais
c'est pour ça que je pense que en gros
je vais caricaturer mais pas totalement
vous demandez la loi demande aux
collectivités de faire un effort
mais un régime constant ou presque
et les forces et les communes
qui vont le produire pas les communes
vous n'êtes pas beaucoup parlé des
régions et des départements sans doute
parce que non les besoins ne sont pas
les mêmes parce qu'il y a le besoin
d'ingénierie ça fait longtemps que c'est
un satisfait si vous saviez ce qu'il
pense de la de la de la de la cellule
bâtisse scolaire de l'éducation
nationale
oui oui mais ils sont aussi ils sont
aussi très proactifs elles sont aussi
très proactives elles sont elles font
nécessaires
je dirais pas comme ça mais vous
exprimez comme vous voulez mais mais
c'est un sujet moi je pense que
l'effort que s'apprête à faire les
collectivités méritent d'être accompagné
je pense que vous gagneriez à plaider
pour une aide dédiée puisque c'est une
cause non pas nationale mais européenne
ou la lutte contre le réchauffement
sur
France ruralité qui est un peu un
programme de politique publique un objet
en faveur de nos villages ruraux que la
première ministre devrait annoncer fin
de semaine prochaine
et dans le package France ruralité il y
a parce que j'ai vraiment compris ça
dans mes visites dans les territoires
sans projet qui vont être sans chef de
projet
qui va être financé par l'État qui vont
être déployés dans les services de
l'État donc auprès du préfet au service
de qui des maires ruraux
ça veut dire quand même rural lèvera il
aura droit de 1 2 3 jours 5 jours une
semaine 15 jours d'ingénierie pour
analyser son projet si c'est plus long
alors il y a un package séréma qui sera
ou autre bureau d'études avec lequel on
aura des marchés et qui viendra
travailler le projet sous l'angle
technique sous l'angle
prospective sous l'angle mais la
première chose que fera ce chef de
projet quand il sera recruté et qu'il
arrivera dans les territoires au service
des réalités première chose ce qui va
faire l'inventaire de toutes les
ingéniers qui existent pour être avant
tout quelqu'un qui active les
ingénieries donc l'ingénierie
pour de la rénovation d'école le maire
qui le saura pas il sera ce chef de
projet ingénierie qui va être partenaire
des élus ruraux il va fléchir vers la
Caisse des Dépôts quand on sera dans un
département dans lequel il y a une
agence technique forte en ingénierie
travaillera maintenant avec elle donc ça
va être des chefs de projets qui vont
être capables de faire de l'ingénierie
prospective pour ceux qui veulent porter
un projet territoire de l'ingénierie
technique s'il y a pas dans le
département de la générique financière
et donc il va se positionner en
coordonnateur va lui-même faire de
l'ingénierie des prédiagnostics
mais j'ai tellement vous imaginez en
période actuelle financière obtenir le
financement de 100 chefs de projet
ingénierie que pour nos villages donc
j'espère que il jouera vraiment ce rôle
de diagnostic de l'ingénierie et de et
d'accompagnement lui personnellement ou
bien par des marchés publics et ça
gratuitement et l'autre chose que
auprès du préfet de chaque département
le préfet pourra décider de le mettre si
le DDT est très dynamique et qu'il est
dans l'aménagement et que les projets
relèvent plutôt d'aménagement de le
mettre à côté si les bureaux sont à côté
du DDT mais en principe nous on demande
qu'il soit sous le préfet de département
au service des villages ruraux
et
ce besoin en ingénierie il est il est
réel et il nous fallait répondre et donc
il va poser son diagnostic et j'espère
que ça va marcher à prendre on verra si
ça suffit pas on verra mais déjà
recrutons ces 100 chefs de projet et
gratuitement et après le deuxième
la deuxième ambition que porte France
ruralité mais là ça va me prendre du
temps
j'ai une dizaine de départements et
trois régions qui sont d'accord pour
l'instant c'est
que à l'issue de ce travail d'ingénierie
qui qui est fait cette ingénierie
sauf sur le bâti parce qu'on voit que
l'ingénierie elle est faite par la
caisse la banque des territoires et que
finalement ils accompagnent aussi en
ingénierie en financement mais qui est
fait l'ingénierie
quand on sera labellisé France ruralité
au terme de cette ingénierie Monsieur le
Préfet réunir un département région nous
mettrons 40%
obligatoirement le label France ruralité
parce que c'est un collabel parce que je
le conçois avec départements région ce
que je voudrais que autour de Monsieur
le Préfet le représentant de la région
quand on va parler du financement du
projet du village et bien la région a
dit je mets 20 le département est dit je
mets 20 6 10 qui mettent pas 20 c'est
pas un problème ils auront 60 le
département est et
la commune pour l'instant
j'avance avec ceux avec lesquels on va
pouvoir conventionner et il y aura un
seul dossier
issu du travail d'ingénierie quatre
pages qui vont vous permettre pas un
deuxième et un troisième dossier quand
vous êtes labellisé France ruralité et
que Monsieur préférait mini conférence
des cofinanceurs et bien vous saurez
vous avez 60% et c'est fait c'est les
quatre pages
issus qui sont la demande de subvention
donc j'ai essayé de rester très simple
sur le financement mais il me faut
l'accord il me faut une délibération de
chaque département donner l'accord et de
chaque région pour avoir ce
confidentiellement mais qui n'a pas
entendu un maire dire qu'il en a marre
de constituer des dossiers et là on
parle de mon temps qui sont pas
faramineux parce qu'on parle de demande
de subvention de village donc et nous on
s'engage à 40 et on leur demande de
mettre 20 chacun
j'ai essayé de leur donner envie de
simplifier la démarche et la deuxième
volet que vous développiez il y avait
donc François réalité dont j'avais envie
de vous parler dans son rôle de
coordination et vous avez commencé par
un autre sujet auquel j'avais un petit
élément de réponse
je me souviens plus
tu as noté
France ruralité l'ingénierie
votre propos
sur
oui et l'emprunt alors deuxième petite
élément vous avez pas de surprise parce
que c'est la même le même regard que ce
que je vous ai déjà dit sur
l'investissement qui est pas de la même
nature chaque fois est adapté mais là
l'emprunt
quel est
la durée moyenne en France de
remboursement de l'emprunt dans les
collectivités
non non la durée moyenne en France c'est
à dire que le taux d'endettement de
toutes nos communes je vous ai dit qu'il
y avait 50 milliards de trésorerie je
vous ai dit il y a 30 milliards
d'épargnettes quel est le taux
on peut se présenter devant des
électeurs quand on a un délai de 8 à 10
ans c'est la moyenne mais en France on
est entre autour de 4 et demi
on est très loin et on est à 4h30 4
années et demi en moyenne donc oui c'est
une moyenne mais que dit merci eux ils
regardent en moyenne et regarde il y a 5
milliards de trésorerie un teint donc
avec un retour sur investissement de
quatre années et demi d'année de ce taux
de remboursement de l'emprunt
de rembourse la durée de remboursement
voilà quatre années et demi donc
qu'est-ce que dit merci mais pourquoi
les collectivités ne s'endettent pas et
quand vous me je retrouve ce que moi
j'ai pensé est-ce que pense les maires
ils aiment pas s'endetter mais il faut
un peu s'endetter surtout quand les taux
d'intérêt sont pas très élevés même 3%
ça fait peur parce qu'on empruntait tout
ça hein et on se dit oh là là trois
c'est cher mais ça reste pas cher et
il faut améliorer la qualité de vie nos
concitoyens il y a de l'argent en
investissement l'argent est pas si cher
que ça il faut s'endetter quand ta
commune ne peut mais aujourd'hui les
communes sont saines très saines peu
endettés on ne l'épargne et c'est pour
ça que quand nous on va demander plus
que les 320 millions de plus qu'on a eu
cette année et comme on apparaît des
enfants gâtés avec Christophe Vichy
quand on est à Bercy on est dit qu'il
s'endettent qui dépense l'argent qu'ils
ont mis de côté globalement il y a
toujours et c'est pour ça que ceux qui
sont plus en difficulté n'hésitez pas à
nous le faire remonter pour qu'on
travaille avec eux et qu'on essaie de
trouver des solutions mais
alors là les critères qui visent à ils
sont en train d'être définis je crois
que je vais signer la circulaire non
que l'on a en provision sur 2024 pour
accompagner des communes les critères
sont pas finalisés
il y a pas il y a pas ce critère
seulement pour accompagner la commune
il en fait partie sûrement bien sûr
là par exemple je suis confronté à mes
trois communes là qui on a pris des de
la détoxique à l'époque c'est des maires
précédents
toxiques qui ont été donc on s'occupe
d'eux s'ils ont été pris par des maires
précédents et on va essayer de trouver
des solutions
vous avez encore des questions non
écoutez il me reste à vous remercier
madame la ministre pour cette
disponibilité et vous explications
madame messieurs merci à vous également
et puis chers collègues je vous souhaite
une bonne soirée
c'était la dernière